so yesterday during this segment I spent
about 20 minutes explaining why in my
view the psychology field is in large
part though not in every case a scam and
as it happens I feel much the same way
about the university system not every
college is a massively overpriced waste
of money but most are not every college
student is getting builk out of
thousands of dollars for an education
that isn't worth the paper it's printed
on but um but but most are so when when
you can combine these two
things the psychology field and the
college system that's when you really
get into some very questionable
territory again not always but often
that brings us to Joshua grubs a
psychology Professor who just uh wrote
an article for the hill announcing that
the people concerned about the effects
of pornography are engaged in a moral
panic and should probably just calm down
now I'm going to read a a sizable chunk
of this and then respond to it's an
excellent window in into not only the
flaws and the pornopgraphyspelled
grounding in what careful re scientific
research has taught us about pornography
use as a psychology professor and
addiction researcher I have made a
career out of understanding pornography
use and its effects publishing dozens of
scientific studies on the topic across
that work the most consistent finding is
that simple narratives like porn is bad
or porn is good are flawed such
assertions and that argument and the
arguments that underpin them always miss
key information are almost always wrong
those who foment Panic about pornography
often claim that pornography leads to
addiction and mental health problems
damages the brain results in violence
against women and drives epidemics of
sexual dysfunction the science does not
currently support these claims now
notice how this is Being Framed he says
that the statement porn is bad is flawed
it's a false narrative he says that we
know it's flawed and false because of
the science so he's entirely ignoring
the fact that when most people say porn
is bad they don't mean it in a
scientific sense good and bad are
Concepts that extended beyond the
scientific realm there is
no science of good and bad science can
tell us a lot about you know things in
the physical world but it cannot tell us
whether those things are good or
bad that is a qualitative and moral
judgment it's not a scientific one but
we'll return to that in a moment
continuing claims that pornography is
inherently addictive are without basis
some people do become out of control in
their use of pornography but the same
could be said of exercise shopping or
even working yet there is no rush to
label most of those things as addictive
because not every habitual behavior is
an addiction and just because some
people develop real problems with
pornography it does not mean that
pornography is inherently likely to lead
to those types of problems for most
users the scientific and psychiatric
communities do not currently consider
excessive pornography use to be an
addictive disorder dozens of Studies
have demonstrated that most people who
view pornography do not feel addicted or
out of control among people who do say
they feel addicted the reasons for those
feelings range from real concerns about
how much they view pornography to simple
feelings of Shame about their sexual
behaviors okay let's break this down I
actually agree that pornography is not
addictive but that's because I take a
much much much more conservative view of
addiction than most people and certainly
most psychologists to my mind the word
Addiction only makes sense it is only
useful when we're talking about the
physical chemical dependencies
experienced by you know fentanyl addicts
and crackheads and and people like that
everything outside of chemical
dependency is less an addiction and more
a compulsion or a very strong habit but
in my opinion but that's a different
argument than what Professor grubs is is
presented uh instead he links to studies
that he says show that most people who
view pornography don't feel addicted now
the problem here problems here are
numerous and obvious first of all he
employs a common method all throughout
this article of linking to one study
after another without taking the time to
actually explain what these studies say
exactly and how they were conducted what
their methodologies and findings were
Etc instead he simply provides a link to
the studies knowing of course that
almost nobody is going to follow the
links and actually read the many walls
of text on the other end now of course
I'm one of the weird people who will
read a study when somebody claims it
proves their case except here I
discovered that in some cases the
studies he links to are paywalled and
you have to give your credit card
information to get the full text and
that's where I draw the line personally
the studies that I could read were
extremely weak at best and you could
tell they're weak just from the way he
describes them most porn users don't
feel addicted
is that really the bar we're setting in
order for it to be concerned most have
to be addicted do we apply that to
anything else I mean most alcohol
drinkers are non-alcoholics in fact only
around 8% of men who drink alcohol are
alcoholics yet I'm pretty sure that
Professor grubs would say that
alcoholism is a major problem you know
if I try to dismiss concerns about
alcoholism by saying well well most
people who drink alcohol aren't
alcoholics I'd be laughed out of the
room as I should be it's like most it
has to be most in order for it to be an
issue 8% is a high enough number to
qualify as a significant issue for
alcohol which is strange because one of
his studies that he links to and assumes
we won't read says that 11% of male porn
users reported that they are addicted
now sure 11% isn't most but given the
number of people who watch porn it's
extremely high we're talking about
millions of people here yet uh this is
all sort of irrelevant because it's all
based on self reported data from porn
users who are telling us whether they
personally feel addicted or not is this
psychology Professor really so clueless
about human psychology that he doesn't
understand that many times addicts don't
feel addicted and won't tell you that
they are addicted even if everybody else
in their lives can clearly see that they
are does he truly not understand that
like I've encountered many alcoholics in
my day who who certainly would not
describe themselves as alcoholics on a
survey that doesn't mean they're not
alcoholics just as I'm quite sure that
there are plenty of men who watch porn
for hours a day and it's destroying
their lives and destroying their
marriages yet if you ask them they'll
tell you that they're fine and their
porn use is not a problem this is called
denial which again is something that a
guy who teaches psychology should be
able to to grasp moving on quote
similarly although pornography can be
associated with mental health concerns
most evidence suggests that links
between its use and things like
depression anxiety and stress are not
causal in nature several Studies have
found no direct links between how often
people use pornography and their likely
of experiencing mental health problems
in the future people experiencing
depression and anxiety might use
pornography more but there's no
conclusive evidence that the pornography
is the cause rather than the effect now
once again we get the link to the
studies that supposedly makes the case
but he doesn't tell us anything about
the studies specifically you'll notice
that the professor so far has not
actually made a single complete argument
instead he he just assures us that other
people have made these arguments and we
can trust what they said whoever they
are exactly and whatever it is they
actually said according to Forbes
January is the hottest month for hiring
and business owners and hiring managers
are on on the hunt for top talent which
is no easy task if you're currently
hiring you can probably relate it's
challenging to find qualified candidates
and that's why you need zip recruiter
zip recruiter's powerful matching
technology finds the right people for
your roles and right now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com Walsh
immediately after you post your job zip
recruiter smart technology start showing
you candidates whose skills and
experience m it to encourage top
candidates to respond to your job post
even sooner Zipperer lets you send them
a personal invite to apply and as your
rate candidates Zipperer sends you more
of the ones you like from the thousands
of new job Seekers who join the site
this month find the talent you need to
fill all of your roles with zip
recruiter see for yourself why four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day just go to this exclusive
web address right now to try zi
recruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
Walsh again that's ziprecruiter.com
wsh zip recruiter smartest way to hire
one of the studies he provides uh he
provides required me to pay $17.95 for a
PDF and the other demanded $40 for
access to the PDF uh if you aren't
willing to invest that money and I'm not
then all you can do is read the abstract
and here's what I can glean from those
one of them apparently found that there
is in fact a link between psychological
distress and pornography use except it
determined the study determined that the
real cause of the psychological distress
is the fact that the porn users
perceived themselves to be addicted even
though we were just told that there's
not really a problem with people
perceiving themselves to be addicted so
whatever um so they're saying it it's
the perception of the addiction that
causes distress not the porn itself the
study claims now the idea that a study
Based on self-reported data can somehow
discern that psychological distress is
rooted in a perception of porn addiction
rather than the porn itself is just
frankly stupid stupid I mean here we
have the researchers taking the
subjective reports of the participants
and using their subjective reports to
arrive at their own subjective analysis
of the root cause of the participants
distress in other words this is totally
useless this is not science and yet the
upshot is that this study no matter how
it tries to frame
it does find a link between
psychological distress and porn now the
other study is even worse for the
professor's case this one uses a sample
of 775 female and 514 male Croatian high
school students who were surveyed six
times over the course of a few years
here's what the study found quote we
observed no significant correspondence
between growth in pornography use and
changes in the two indicators of
psychological well-being over time in
either female or male
participants okay what does that
mean well it means that as the
participants used more pornography they
did not report Fe feeling any worse
about
themselves over the years now if you're
a critical thinker you might note that
polling high school students about how
they feel is not even close to an
accurate way of measuring their actual
well-being and more importantly you
might also note that this only is
measuring changes in their psychological
state from the Baseline and the Baseline
is whatever their psychological state
was at the start of the study but what
if these kids started using porn
before high school as many of them
surely did and negative psychological
effects had already been suffered before
the study started in other words what if
their psychological Baseline itself had
been negatively impacted by porn use
isn't that possible well yes it's not
just possible in fact this study the
very study the professor cited as proof
that porn doesn't negatively impact
mental health actually showed that it
probably did negatively impact mental
health reading now it says quote
however a significant negative
association was found between female
adolescent pornography use and
psychological well-being at Baseline
this study's findings do not corroborate
the notion that pornography use in
Middle to late adolescence contributes
to adverse psychological well-being but
do not rule out such a link during an
earlier developmental
phase so this is what happens when you
read the studies you quite often
discover that people who cite studies
are full of crap and from there the
professor assures us that despite claims
to the contrary porn is not stunting
neural development or changing people's
brains for this he provides no links no
citations no evidence not even any
studies nothing he just asserts it and
as for whether there's an association
between porn and sexual violence he
tells us this quote while associations
between sexual violence and violent
pornography have been found in some
research these links are not present in
all
studies oh so there are multiple studies
finding a link between porn and sexual
violence like that's the headline here
but he says that's okay because not
every study has shown that so not every
study shows a link between porn and
sexual violence and not everyone is
addicted to porn and so therefore it's
okay if you're keeping track at home in
this article that's supposed to be
defending porn we have been told that
some Studies have found a link between
psychological distress and porn use and
between sexual violence and porn use
this again is in an article claiming
that there's a moral Panic around porn
yet somehow I come away from this
article hating porn even more than I did
before I read
it and after utterly failing to make his
case the professor concludes this way
quote ultimately pornography is one form
of media in a world that is more
saturated than ever with media of all
forms pornography has flourished in the
internet era so to at podcast streaming
television and digitized music it is
natural for parents Educators and policy
makers to be concerned about children's
exposure to sexual media it's also
normal for people to worry about how new
forms of media are affecting people of
all ages but moral panics based on fear
and pseudo science don't lead to
effective parenting education or policy
instead what is needed is real support
for science seeking to understand how
all media is affecting people and a
willingness to understand the science
before making Regulatory and policy
changes so that's the argument in
closing um drawing a moral equivalence
between podcasts and pornography that's
how he wraps things
up that's the science apparently except
the problem aside from the fact that the
science as we've seen is mostly bogus
and doesn't even say what he's saying it
says the problem is that this is not a
scientific question porn is indeed bad
and it is bad because it dehumanizes and
degrades and debases everybody involved
porn turns people into objects and it is
bad for people to be made into objects
it is bad for them to be treated as
objects and to and to see others as
objects
now what does the science say about the
degradation and objectification of the
human person nothing you cannot quantify
moral degradation and objectification in
a scientific study science can't tell us
whether someone has been degraded or
whether degradation is a good or bad or
neutral thing just like science can't
tell you that it's morally wrong to
gossip or lie or steal you know if I
steal from you and you confront me about
it
and and you tell me that you're angry
that that I stole it would make no sense
for me to respond oh yeah well show me
the study that says I shouldn't have
stolen from
you stealing is wrong because it's
stealing because you're taking a thing
that doesn't belong to you I I don't
know that because of the science I just
know because it's true because I'm a
human being with a conscious mind people
get upset about stealing you know
there's a lot of stealing and looting
and shoplifting happening right now
across the country people are rightly
angry about it that's not a moral
panic and even if it was science
wouldn't be able to tell us that science
can't tell us about moral panics one way
or another because science doesn't know
what moral is and
isn't Professor grub set out to prove
that the concerns over porn are a moral
panic and then proceeded to write a
lengthy article that says nothing at all
about the subject the article is
supposed to be
about like if you want to say that that
it's a moral panic over pornography you
need to make a moral
argument tell me why so people it's a
moral Panic with for moral Panic means
that people are reacting to to to
something and and and seeing it as a you
know as a moral crisis when it's not
right so so explain why it's not a moral
crisis explain why it's not a moral
problem he makes no argument he doesn't
there's not one sentence that even comes
close to making that kind of argument
all he has are studies which are really
not all that scientific and which don't
even say what he claims they say but
even if they were and they did they
still would never be able to tell us
whether porn is morally bad or
not but it is morally bad profoundly so
because again it degrades and lessens
both the performer and viewer alike you
don't need a study to tell you that
that's what your soul is for and we all
have souls even psychology professors
believe it or not and this particular
psychology Professor is today
cancelled if You' like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt wall Show Twitter page
hope to see you there Godspeed